c'est peut-être à quoi va ressembler une
entrée sur les chantiers de construction
dans l'avenir
les travailleurs qui passent tour à tour
dans une capsule sanitaire c'est un
système en 3 étapes
première étape la détection de la
température deuxième étape lavage de
mains sans contact wazemmes et appelons
de désinfection dans la zone des
infections l'ouvrier est aspergée
d'acide hypochloreux un produit
notamment utilisé dans l'industrie
cosmétique comme agent nettoyant de la
peau est aussi dans l'industrie
alimentaire pour désinfecter les
surfaces de travail
on ne peut pas réinventer la roue mais
c'est ont jeté un produit qui fait
cavalier marque qui 80 fois plus
puissant qu'un loup de javel
ces ouvriers qui ont essayé la capsule
ont apprécié l'expérience
je trouve ça l'fun de savoir qu'on peut
travailler tout en restant s'assurer la
halle fonde reste en santé le tout le
monde delphine et je ne sais pris ici
c'est ce qu'il faut pour être en santé
on va le faire
maxime caparros casse a eu l'idée de
concevoir cette capsule en raison des
mesures sanitaires imposées à
l'industrie de la construction sur les
chantiers en ce moment les travailleurs
doivent répondre à un questionnaire sur
leur état de santé avant de commencer
leur journée se laver les mains
régulièrement y porter un masque
s'ils doivent travailler à moins de deux
mètres d'un collègue avec des entrées
cento on va passer un travailleur ou 20
secondes versus paraître sur des
chantiers ça va prendre un trou en trou
minutes avec les formulaires et le temps
c'est de l'argent
une fois qu'elle sera homologué maxime
caparros casse vendra sa capsule au prix
de 15 mille dollars
selon lui des dizaines de milliers
d'entreprises au pays notamment dans le
secteur de la construction et de la
fabrication pourrait être intéressé ici
olivier d'achat radio-canada terme